thank you what it sounds like
[Music]
thank you very much thank you
sounds like you people have not stopped
celebrating from 4:20 yesterday it was
4:20 yesterday or as you know how I call
it Christmas
what no everybody was celebrating it
over at the United Terminal they had
dragged the guy off Jefferson Airplane
know it's a hard day for Republicans
they have to decide which they hate more
medical or marijuana I mean look we got
a plan the health care plan Trump did
you see him the other day the health
care plan
this is except this word for word did
the plan gets better and better and
better and it's gotten really good and a
lot of people are liking it a lot and
then Ivanka gave him a lollipop so I
mean
[Applause]
I don't want to see their head is up
their ass but they misplaced an aircraft
carrier this week that's kind of hard
did you see that trumpet trumpet like a
week ago said you know because we're
about to go to war with North Korea no
biggie
trust that we have an armada heading
towards North Korea actually it was
heading the exact opposite direction
halfway around the world who knew maps
were so complicated
who knew nobody nobody move
it's okay we fixed this Trump put Jared
Kushner in charge of figuring out which
way is east well
he's new to confrontations with North
Korea his first idea was to make Hawaii
build a wall I mean what's it did you
speaking of Hawaii do you see what our
Attorney General Jeff Sessions said
about Hawaii
if this guy is from Alabama by the way
he was he was bitching about Trump's
travel ban being struck down by a court
in Hawaii and he said again word for
word I really am amazed he said that a
judge sitting on an island in the
Pacific can issue an order that stops
the president yeah what do they think
they are a state what would Hawaii know
about national security what have they
ever been attacked
forget the wall we need to build a
blackboard because the sequel Trump's
whole MO if I can get this right after
almost 100 days seems to be a plan a is
just talk out of your ass we can have
much better health care way less money
we can get rid of the debt very quickly
wipe out Isis very quickly okay then he
finds out that's all [ __ ]
plan B develop a policy based on whoever
you just talked to he said this week
that he found out that Korea was
complicated because he was talking to
the president of China and he said and I
quote after listening for 10 minutes I
realized it's not so easy
[Applause]
this is a part I'm not making up our
president is getting his talking points
on Korea from China wasn't Amuro sir
around or some other expert what about
did you see who we add to the White
House yesterday he had Sarah Palin and
Ted Nugent Sarah Palin and Ted Nugent or
as their fans called them the slow and
the furious and oh and I'm sorry and Kid
Rock to complete - to complete the axis
of redneck and there they are there's a
picture of anything this is them just a
prior to heading out to the Rose Garden
to shoot some varmints for lunch
but I know what you really want me to
talk about Bill O'Reilly
[Applause]
we have been following this story for a
while it has not been going well for
Bill and apparently this week had alas
draw a black woman who worked at Fox
News came forward and said he used to
call her hot chocolate which I find
shocking Fox News hired a black woman oh
there was universal condemnation Sean
Spicer today said come on even Hitler
didn't call black women hot Chuck but
yeah Bill O'Reilly gone that is the end
of an era
first Lawrence Welk died now Bill
O'Reilly is gone my question how is the
craftmatic adjustable bed company
supposed to reach its customers
and now the big man at Fox News is a
Sean Hannity and amid all the troubles
over there I want you to know Hannity
remains completely free of any sex
scandal unless you count the nightly
on-air [ __ ] he gives to President
Trump